>> Chris: IT'S TIME FOR SPRING
BREAK REGRETS.
SPRING BREAK REGRETS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Chris: WE ARE DEEP IN THE
THROWS OF THE ANNUAL SPRING
BREAK RITUAL WHERE COLLEGE
STUDENTS DESCEND ON PLACES LIKE
DAYTONA BEACH AND CANCUN.
BACONALIAS FOR MEMORIES AND
STDs TO LAST A LIFETIME.
REGRETTABLY MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
THERE.
ACTUALLY, I DIDN'T GO TO A COOL
SPRING BREAK STUFF WHEN I WAS IN
COLLEGE.
THAT'S WHEN I STARTED TO WORKING
FOR MTV.
NOTHING EVEN HAPPENED AT THAT
POINT.
I WANT TO YOU GIVE ME AS MANY
SPRING BREAK REGRETS AS YOU
POSSIBLY CAN.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
BEN GLEIB.
>> ENTERING THE WET UNDERPANTS
CONTEST.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MOSHE.
>> TOSSING THOSE BEADS AT MY
MOM.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BEN.
>> ONE ROOM 12 DUDES.
>> Chris: POINTS. FORTUNE.
>> PUTTING THOSE PING PONG BALLS
IN MY VAGINA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BEN.
>> THRUSTING HIM WHEN HE SAID HE
WASN'T A GUY.
>> Chris: OH, JESUS. BEN.
>> NOT GETTING GOOD WITH GIRLS
UNTIL A DECADE AFTER SPRING
BREAK.
>> Chris: POINTS. FORTUNE.
>> BLOWING ALL MY GUY FRIENDS,
BECAUSE IT'S NOW JUST AWKWARD.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MOSHE.
>> SIGNING THE RELEASE FOR JEWS
GONE WILD.
>> Chris: POINTS,
MOSHE.
>> AGREEING TO CO-STAR IN THE
DONKEY SHOW.
>> Chris: POINTS.
FORTUNE.
>> GOING WILD IN FRONT OF THAT
CAMERA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MOSHE.
>> INVITING ROBERT DURST ON MY
SPEED BOAT.
>> Chris: BEN.
>> BLOWING ALL MY GUY FRIENDS
NOW IT'S JUST AWKWARD.
>> WAIT A SECOND!
>> Chris: POINTS TO BEN.
FORTUNE.
>> USING MIRACLE WHIP AS SUN
SCREEN.